I'm so excited to have you both here
thank you for joining me on ATT canada
pride this is kinda this is my first
threesome on this show because this
series is fantastic for so many reasons
but before we get into season 2 I want
to know where did the idea for the
series come from because was there just
missing representation you felt yes it
definitely started from a place of
feeling like there was representation
missing and I think we kind of just made
the show that we wanted to watch if when
we were 15 yeah and yeah but really we
were in that we were in the back of a
bar that we used to work at planning
away scheming and the scheme came to
fruition and now we have season 1 which
was so well received so congratulations
on that thank you
what was some of the feedback you heard
from the fans about the series oh my
gosh well I mean it's so wild like the
first three episodes oh my god I'm
jumping over to season 2 already but
like last night I was like in the
YouTube comments
but it's amazing like how I like for
lack of a better term like thirsty the
fandom has been like they in the first
season they actually like named
themselves because they were like there
was like all this Buzzle over twitter of
them being like what is this fandom
called what is this animal what is this
fandom called
and I run the social accounts for fur
barbell along with Gwen and I was like
okay I was like I was like you all can
name yourself and then they did and
they're like now they call themselves
the pop chart so it was like it was very
it was very sweet and like super
endearing and it was like that's it yeah
the response has been like so honestly
like super heart warm we have to see
that people you know care about the show
and and and you know have seen
themselves reflected in the show and so
we have the the response has been like
surprising but like also like extremely
gratifying when you do have something so
successful does that take a little
pressure off moving into season two or
does it put more pressure on to live up
to what the fandom the pop-tarts why
yeah did you feel more pressure
i I did I it didn't like in a different
way because I was like it has to be
better than the first season right and I
think that a lot of shows like in their
second season are like okay all right we
like came out we did something good and
it's like now we got to like take it up
a notch so we did feel I think a bit of
pressure in that sort of a way that we
were like okay there's got to be like
more bad music videos and like music
videos are so much fun in the show a lot
of fun to shoot those because they're
good for you yeah mm-hmm actually the
really awful one in season one was no
fun to shoot at all but ended up being
the most fun thing to put together yeah
afterwards
[Music]
like we wanted it to be this like 90s
sort of like Faith Hill oh it's homage
it's very nice yeah it's at Ray's
nineties I feel like a lot of times in
media the representation of a lesbian is
a certain way it can be very
stereotypical yeah it's funny though
because in the mainstream media you know
it's a lesbian as a joke then then it's
more of that like Oh lesbians are all
ugly kind of stereotyping they wear
plaid bla bla bla bla but if they're
given more screen time they're often
pretty femme looking for lack of a
better term like lipstick lesbians so I
think we kind of ride a line I mean to
be honest the show definitely airs on
the on the femme side of things but I
think we've definitely wanted to play
with the idea that like these pop stars
aren't getting to wear the clothes that
they want to wear um and a lot of famous
people maybe don't get to be who they
really are they're projecting an image
out so what they wear on their downtime
or is not done
not what they wear on the job and now
I've just boiled stereotypes down to
clothing
I love seeing Toronto showcase in the
series
I wore this Toronto fabulous and I want
to wear it because I love the support
you guys have shown the City of Toronto
and so many queer musicians how
important was it to include that in the
series for both of you huge like I
honestly I love the city so much and my
part of my endgame as like a creator and
a producer working and living here is to
like show the world how cool Toronto is
and I think that specifically the queer
scene is just like really exploding and
you know creating some amazing media
here as well so Drake is not the only
music not the only a good representative
of yes
yeah I mean Toronto is just one of the
best cities in in the world it really is
so season 1 for anyone who's hasn't
watched it yet is out now you can watch
entirety of season 1 and you should and
you should binge it and it's amazing
season 2 tell me where it picks up well
at the end of season 1 yes our main
character is Alice Veronica their
breakup has gone public and yeah where
we pick up in season 2 they are stuck on
tour together with Alice's ex-girlfriend
and her band plus her ex-girlfriend
Veronica except that maybe they're back
together secretly but they can't let the
cat out of the bag because everyone is
really excited about their breakup and
it really helps with publicity well for
myself I don't want you two to be back
together
really I don't that's my question do you
feel like a lot of fans want them to be
together okay yes yes so well it's like
it's a new question if there's like
there's a lot of people like I think
that there was many people at the end of
season one who are like Veronica doesn't
deserve a less toxic lady and like Lulu
and Alice are like way more suited for
each other but I think that like some of
my some of my favorite my favorite
couples like in like in all of like
media or literature or whatever are the
ones that like kind of don't really
belong together but like for whatever
reason it sort of works I think deep
down there is a bit of a heart of gold
hmm yes oh for sure right oh yeah she's
like she's like she's fierce but like
she's got that tenderness on the inside
I'm like I think you get to see a little
bit more of that in the second season
what would you say some of the themes of
season 2 are so when we were writing the
second season it was sort of at the peak
of like the me to movement it was last
spring that we were doing it and I felt
like every time I open up my phone
sort of like scroll through things like
aim between our like curious writing
sessions the headlines were like replete
with like another male media mogul who
had been you know tarnished because of
you know sexual misconduct accusations
and so that was a head like that was a
news item that I couldn't get out of my
as we were writing so we're like what
would this look like in a lesbian
context
what does toxic masculinity look like in
in this sort of in this sort of a
setting so we wanted to touch on what
the hashtag me to movement would look
like through a queer land lover so we
explore that more in the back half of
the second season and I think that we I
think that we've done like a pretty
interesting job of like parsing out you
know the I think the sort of small
minutiae and the and the nuance of like
what that looks like because it is
different yeah and so I'm really I'm
really excited for people to to watch
that and perhaps see their own story
reflected in that way because it is
definitely a problematic issue
regardless of gender yeah the appetite
for this show is huge
I know people out there are probably
gonna be wondering season three is that
already spinning in the back of your
minds is that something that's gonna
happen well we need mrs. Netflix to call
us know what you know their number yeah
yeah we have a couple other queer
projects that were working on at the
moment
there's a show that we're hoping to film
this summer that is about a mostly queer
mostly female beer league slowpitch team
oh and like Trinity ball was amazing so
that's like sort of the next like big
thing like on our horizon as creators
and we're very excited about that that's
gonna be some like there's some serious
like amazing queer artists who are going
to be in and involved in that project so
we're so tonight we have to like do that
one or our one thing at a time is what
you're telling me I mean the door is
always open yeah yeah misses an app
looks like wants to like have coffee
yeah let's do this is not works well
congratulations
I'm so happy to see a show like this
that is out there for so many people and
the LGBTQ community so thanks I'm so rad
yeah yeah
you